gentlemen I really want to start with a
sincere thank you for making me laugh
and and thank you for the amount of
blood that you had on set because I
loved it okay it's you know what I mean
I was all in um but before we get
started on why I get to talk to you guys
today uh I am and Nick last time I spoke
to you I asked you about this at the end
I'm gonna ask you about it at the
beginning what do I need to do for face
off too oh well I have to be careful
what I say
um in fact they even said to me the less
I know the better so you can read
between those lines sure I will not
pressure you anymore except to say I
really really would love this to happen
and absolutely and I hope it does yeah
last time we spoke I asked you this
question so I'm going to switch over to
your partner in crime if someone has
actually never seen anything you've done
before what is the first thing you'd
like them watching and why besides
renfeld oh besides renfellow that was my
first answer right there what would I
like them to watch and and why
um uh that's a difficult question I
think
uh perhaps watch the the thing I've been
enjoying shooting a lot at the moment is
the great um the show about Catherine
the Great and and I guess I played that
character for the longest of any
characters that I've played Peter
um and so I I got to explore a lot
within him and and kind of unpack it in
a way that
um with other characters I haven't had
the opportunity to as much so perhaps
that I I I have my own favorite I I
besides around field uh I just saw him
in the menu and I called him I thought
that was very nice that was fantastic I
thought that was one of my favorite
movies or if not my favorite movie all
year he was amazing and him was fine
magnificent yeah you know what we should
be saying well the weatherman the film
that we did yeah yeah I got to play next
song when I was really ten and that I
think is a brilliant movie I I think it
really stands up ago did wonderful work
and Steve the writer it was like really
funny and dark twisters and Nick's
performances is hilarious and um I was
gonna say that's actually an underrated
movie yeah yeah like I don't think
enough people appreciate it sure I agree
with that you know um so I love the
recreation of the original Dracula you
guys getting do those scenes it's
fantastic talk a little bit about
getting to do those specifically filming
those moments because it's you know
that's a huge that original film is it
changed Cinema yeah and getting to
recreate those scenes I can't imagine
what it was like what was like a bit
like Ping Pong so what would happen was
when Nick and I would be on set and then
they would play on video playback and
sound playback Dwight Frye and then we
would hear it and then he would ping
pong and recreate it and then they would
do Bella goes you know I would hear in
ping pong and re-christ it was like
action playback action playback action
until we got into this group and we had
to line it up specifically with the
frame from the the 30s classic so every
move had to match it was a timing and a
vocal thing yeah all of those things it
was very specific in terms of recreating
but all so just magical with like as
fans of the original film to then kind
of get implemented into it in that
fashion was yeah it was very exciting it
was a lot of fun a dream come true
um what I like about your relationship
is that some of it is father-son right
and some of it is complete abuse right
well you know I mean I mean we have
these situations sometimes not talking
about anybody specifically but it
happens in families you get that
sometimes families and also and also
there's a there's care and love between
these two characters you know there was
a moment when you're back at the lair
and and very weak after being burned to
a crisp essentially and it was kind of
like almost like taking care of uh yeah
an elderly relative or something where
it's like not trying to nurse you back
to health and they do have this very
complicated
um
relationship kind of a toxic perverse
love you know that's uh evolved into
something completely untenable which is
where there's too much baggage to unpack
for these two it's where we're getting
the comedy from but it's actually a
pretty serious subject yeah
um when you signed on to do this movie
did Chris or anyone at the studio let
you know how much blood was going to be
practical on set because I think a lot
of people don't realize what it takes to
use that much practical blood in the
resets on set between each take yeah
that was something that I mean it was
something that Chris I know really was
committed to and wanted to do in that
film and is something that could set it
apart from other movies particularly as
well so I mean there was a there was a
lot of blood and the thing I was
mentioning earlier about that is
particularly when you're punching your
head off there's obviously like little
explosives and then a lot of blood and
all these things that have to be timed
out
to the millisecond to to work and be
effective and seem plausible and
believable so then it was a lot of
drilling and rehearsals to make sure
that in those moments everyone was
dialed in to do it correctly on the take
because yeah otherwise it would be a big
cleanup and a reset and and there goes
you there goes your schedule for the day
but I do remember Chris McKay taking me
into his office before
um production even began early on when
he was still talking to me about playing
the role and I hadn't committed yet and
he showed me this wonderful video
sequence of what he wanted to achieve in
this movie the tone of the movie and
right off the get-go I said yes I knew
he was on to something special something
that would be very entertaining and very
surprising I love the shot of you it's
the apartment fight sequence yeah where
you're going down and you're breaking
the dude in half up and you're smiling
at Aquafina I was just standing there so
for a shot like that can you explain to
people watching what it takes to do that
shot it's just fan and also her reaction
the blood everything about that shot's
great yeah
well there's lots of different elements
that go into that James my stunt double
was doing some of the wider shots
because
um we were actually also on our
different units as well at the same time
so he was like surfing a fake
a fake body down on wires and then
there's obviously a huge blood explosion
and Rigs of packs and all that sort of
stuff to go off and then
um Chris McKay came up with the with the
great idea of having kind of a sweet
little wave and smile which is just
completely the opposite of everything
that's happening in that moment to Nora
as I kind of ride this body past it and
demolish it so it was um yeah very fun
cinematic month there is I mean I I
don't normally like to compare actors
but if I had to compare any actor there
is a a slight chaplain-esque flavor to
what he brings as Renfield and some of
those sequences yeah I love your voice
of as Dracula and I I loved your
performance in this can you sort of pull
the curtain back before you step on set
how are you how are you finding the
voice how are you figuring out how you
want to make your version of Dracula on
screen some of it is up to uh
you know what happens empathically in
the imagination I Leave Myself open to
Inspirations that so kind of pop in and
go hello and then they come out
uh much of it uh was something that I
had already developed on vampires kiss
uh meeting my father's voice August
Copla
I think that was the main influence the
look more Christopher Lee and then with
a little and Bancroft uh from Mrs
Robinson thrown in I thought those were
all good models for the character and
then whatever like I said it happened
accidentally through the imagination and
playing the scenes with Nick when you
guys looked at the schedule before
filming began was there a day you had
circled like this is going to be an
amazing day or this is going to be the
most challenging day of this of the
shoot I mean all the because there's a
kind of six key scenes I think between
us five or six maybe and all of those
were so good in my mind as you know that
their relationship is the core of the
movie so they're the ones that are most
important for us to really to really
nail and hit but also the ones I was
looking forward to most because I got to
to work with Nick and and bring them to
life and kind of to get to be in those
moments occasionally I would step out of
body and be like this is incredible you
seeing you in full Dracula mode in those
moments was just something that I'll
treasure yeah I I feel that the scene
early on and all the what we call it the
Picasso look for the character and 20
pounds of Mega with the face and the
body and it was quite extended dialogue
and I was just that was the day that I
was most concerned about that that I
would have the energy and the
wherewithal to get through it but
thankfully it worked out I read that you
saw Nosferatu when you were five years
old and it had an impact on you and I
believe you might be doing Nosferatu
with with Robert I guess unless I'm
wrong about it yeah I was shooting at a
moment exactly so I wanted to know what
was that like seeing that film at a
young age and what can you tease about
your new version of nasarat well see it
had such a huge impact on me this is the
thing about growing up with a a
professor of comparative literature who
was also a doctor of Fine Arts I mean he
was always exposing me to movies that
were
perhaps terrifying for a five-year-old
and nonetheless they stayed it with me
and hence sort of formed where I was
going with my own film work I never
forgot those early German
expressionistic movies Caligari and
nosferati were running in the house all
the time and I would go to bed and have
nightmares about it so of course I had
to do something with it
I made Shadow the vampire I did uh
Vampire's Kiss and try to embody Max
Shrek and count warlock's moves and all
this stuff you know uh I thought Willem
was great in Shadow the NASCAR now
William's okay he's a decent actor he's
all right he'll lay it on his feet uh
yeah in terms of
reimagining that story I mean rubber egg
is I think is one of the most
exceptional and exceptional brilliant
directors we have at the moment and his
approach to storytelling his approach to
being authentic and true and the way he
designed shots and and tells the story
is just remarkable so I'm very excited
by what he's creating in his version of
nosferato I know it's a it's a film that
he's been wanting to make since since he
I think he was eight years old he did a
play of it in school and and and so
directed that and and um to see his
vision come to life is really special uh
Roberts talked to me about the film but
the thing that I love about Robert is
the way that he tries to be as authentic
to the time period yes as possible
whether it be using the film equipment
of the era or whatever he needs to do to
to create it
um are you guys using any sort of
vintage equipment are you doing it have
you started I don't know if you started
we're shooting on film 35
um I don't think the lenses uh you'd
have to quiz them on we are using some
vintage lenses but I don't know if
they're here as specific
so you'd have to ask them that sorry
listen I'm a big fan of the way both of
you are like I'm a big fan of both of
your work I needed to get that right as
I said that but I'm curious for both of
you because you haven't worked together
in a while what do you guys have any
similar Styles when you're on set like
before the scene begins are you psyching
yourself up are you listening to music
like are there similarities and how are
you guys different well I I don't listen
to music because I want to be as
um I want my instrument to be open to
whatever I can sounds ridiculous but
grab something Beyond meaning my
imaginations I don't want anything
cluttering that
but the difference on this movie than
the weatherman was I was the lead of the
weatherman he was supporting
on this movie he's the lead he's
Renfield and I'm supporting so I had a
chance to for me as a supporting actor
my job is to
just that support the lead so I had to
find out where he was going and what
pace he was setting with the comic
timing and also watching him flip into
vulnerability on a dime and grab Pathos
and do things that were completely brand
new with the Renfield character so that
informed where I could go and is Dracula
so that it was it would coalesce as a as
a whole piece that we were one really
working together like jazz
yeah I mean and for me the thing that
you know when I was 14 working with Nick
it was uh kind of just an overwhelming
experience where you take all that and
can appreciate it but you can't fully
grasp or understand it so now getting to
to work with him again as an adult I was
just in awe of the the the detail and
where he draws inspiration from and the
fun that he's having and keeping it
fresh and Alive within scene so those
are all things I'm just like
in the back of my mind I'm I'm there and
I'm trying to give my performance but
also I'm just trying to like filtrate
things into my bank to keep to store up
to try and be more like him as an actor
and and learn and be better at the craft
myself I learned from him I mean I
always say stay a student you're never a
master or a master you stay in a
student's mind because you'll learn
something I have to wrap it I just want
to give a shout out to Chris Brewster
who did these yeah he's incredible yeah
he uh did some great work on this oh
yeah yeah it was important to me that
Dracula mood like a cobra or a big cat
on attack and he helped me find that it
was really uh
those scenes with Dracula on attack were
very carefully designed with Brewster on
that note I'm going to say
congratulations thank you thank you so
much for your time